[Music]
for months now I've been listening to
all the young people in my office
talk about tinder a social networking
site where you can find people in your
area you've never met they're in your
vicinity and they're ready to meet and
maybe hook up naturally because I'm a
creep I'm intrigued find out about this
but I didn't want to do it alone
so I got the help of a young hot
Hollywood stud mr. dave Franco hey Dave
now you and I are going to explore a
tinder together you okay you seem a
little nervous I'm a little nervous what
are you nervous about um it's gonna get
it's gonna go weird yes not gonna get
weird at all no together we're going to
I think you have your camera on you were
just taking a picture of your crotch yes
Dave yes I know good ones tender all
right well the way we start is we build
our profiles okay now my suggestion is
because we're known people and clearly
very desirable maybe we should go by
different names I like that but I think
we should still use our pictures okay so
that when these ladies or men Runnymede
sure because that's how it's really
gonna go right right when we switch
right the grinder just to clarify you
you know nothing about tinder but you
definitely know about the existence of
Grindr I know Brian you're cold
whenever you don't see me on television
right come on but know where you are
yeah let's build our profiles yeah we
aren't should I do like the classic like
I don't know you're taking the picture
but I'm having a great time well that's
just looks like your masturbating I take
some big photos of you now you get some
of me women like a guy who's busy who's
got things to do I think I got I'm gonna
be ship Whitley like that remember that
ship Whitley cuz you know what if we get
in the zone and the deal have to go down
I don't want to freeze up and say Conan
what's my name
okay okay my name very Kip Whitley
what's your name Jenga surround stone
stone I'm gonna lie a little bit about
my age do it you realize what we're
doing now is something that's probably
never been done before we are lying on
the Internet I'm 42 years old and people
see people tell me I look like Conan
O'Brien I enjoy wearing Crocs for their
style over their comfort
here I look like a poor man's dave
franco yes de frança i like chai lattes
that's something a woman would like
right i like chai lattes and me up here
I love chai lattes and showering okay
right my first one is neat and about me
is not looking for DTF what's the DTF is
down to me you talk that way at home me
I'm not gonna go with Robin I'm gonna
say no to Paul let you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna be picky it for ya
I'm just gonna go on a string of yeses
at this point I'm going I'm saying yes
to Liza cuz that's my wife's name I
think it's very sweet they don't say yes
I'm tender but someone's the same name
listen mother at my children what do you
what are you looking for over there why
don't any of us really looking for that
special someone daddy who's going to
change my life for a period of like 20
minutes sure anyone I'm not gonna fit
girls whatever we should switch for a
little bit
Gloria it's a match 15 seconds and you
Gloria 74 is the number I glory what do
people say like what will she send me
for so I should probably be talking and
older you know hello that Rory off you
are I have not heard back yet from the
74 year old woman who I agreed to meet
so that right I am so lonely I just I
just corrected it I am and turned it
into Obama President Obama is sending
this huh look what I just got a message
from Gloria know she's gonna cheer up
cheer I said I'm so lonely
cheer up I'm being consoled not the wind
by a 74 year old woman how about you
could help me cheer up in person
Oh Matt yes let me say Oh Tammy
all right this happened oh yeah
Gloria saying yes to you
[Applause]
so now my assistant get in here is my
assistant Sona okay you guys do that I'm
gonna write Gloria you know understand
[Applause]
where there's been a little bit of a
inequality here in how we're scoring
dave has how many how many matches have
you had so far nine maybe okay not okay
you know how many I had one Gloria she's
in her 70s and then she quickly dropped
me you know this happens I wish there
was a way that we could know their
address even if they didn't want us to
know it and then we could go there and
make them like us
beautiful miles away this is the one
this is the one great sense I said hey
this is dave Franco I'm filming a bit
with Conan O'Brien would you be
interested in meeting up with us yes she
said that is a hell of a pickup line lol
yes okay phase two this is our tinder
van what do you think I think is very
inviting this thing says here on the
hunt here on the prowl we are on the
prowl let's say things when it took off
for me you would watch me right this is
how I do it I'm like I'm like a bug
that's trapping us back I think Courtney
is going to love this van we should
probably get rid of the duct tape
[Music]
humming corny [ __ ] Whitley Jake it's
brown stoner coming to kill you
hey ru we'd love to but we're going to
meet a girl we met on tinder yeah yeah
it's pretty odd you know we have to have
a nickname for this van I call this
brown lightening round light brown
lightning sounds like a symptom route
light of intestinal disorder how much
more duct tape yeah I don't know I think
they use you know what I'm gonna make it
clear right now they use the duct tape
to put the cameras in so it's
unfortunate accident that it's in the
car we'll get rid of it I have never
more felt like a murderer on the prowl
this doesn't feel good news van guy ugh
I was gonna ask if you disliked that
feeling full heartedly yes well no
there's part of me that feels it almost
feels like a second skin
it feels great natural well there she is
hi Courtney how are you you're beautiful
look at you nice to see I'm Conan day
nice day
China okay just a quick ok this is nice
Wow I love your house you responded to
this gentleman what is it that you liked
about well let me clarify though from
your perspective I was I was genius
round stone 38 years old and you like
that name I told it Oh what about my
name chip Whitley I want to throw it D
at the beginning of Jamie's Dollar Baby
everybody hold on a second you just said
he's got the natural looks what's wrong
with what I'm calling like a Clint
Eastwood baby I'm moving in like nine
dimensions right now now Courtney
Courtney be honest watch this this is
actually the quickest he's gotten that
open look at that
Courtney would you like to have a seat
have a seat
next week I don't mind the duct tape
this is this is not yeah this is for
mounting the cameras would anyone like
some champagne what do you think it's a
good yeah I'm doing better with you I
applied to me on tinder tonight
what's your name Marcus Marcus want to
see a movie or something your fan yeah
got Marcus Marcus is with me
you got Courtney right we're good this
is what the Internet can do it can bring
a bunch of people who were strangers
just an hour ago together in the night
onto the street outside a really creepy
van where they hold themselves for a
little too long and then probably never
see each other again
[Applause]
today Franco amazing guy elsewhere
thanks to Courtney for more from my
night with dave franco go to team
koco.com
[Applause]
you